Sheryl Sandberg and the cadre of women
who are writing about the problems women
have that are creating barriers for
their success whether it's confidence or
it's being bossy or it is being
perceived as somehow less friendly or
desirable if you are successful are all
fine these are not new ideas these are
ideas that have been around since Matina
Horner 40 years ago wrote her famous
fear of success study where she showed
that women were afraid of what success
would do to them and she did a fantastic
research project where she asked women
from very elite colleges and men from
elite colleges to answer a prompt and
the prompt was Jane finds herself at the
top of her medical school class and from
man it was John finds himself at the top
of his medical school class and the men
would write about John's wonderful
success and how he would prosper and
have a wonderful family and wife and the
women would write things like Jane will
be torn limb from limb she will be
miserable for the rest of her life she's
never going to be you know happy and
based on this matino Horner said women
have an internal block that prevents
them from being successful because
they're afraid of its impact now this
was 40 years ago
so what we're hearing today from people
like Sheryl is very much the same that
there are these internal things they're
societal perceptions and that those are
the real hurdles to women becoming true
leaders globally in leaders whether it's
politics whether it's nonprofits and
whether it's corporate America and I
don't think there's anything necessarily
wrong with that and some of these I I
think are in fact real issues but I
don't think that's the real problem
I think the real problem is the way
institutions are structured and the
paths to leadership today which require
one kind of person to be successful and
that kind of person is the kind of
person who makes the judgment that
working and working at very intense ways
that require sacrifices across many
other elements of an individual's life
is the way you will achieve success and
they're willing to make that choice and
there's nothing wrong with that the
problem is many people and many of them
are women but many of them increasingly
our millennial men don't always want to
exercise their talents in a way that it
means sacrificing so much of the rest of
their life and so if we really want to
tackle why there aren't more women in
leadership and why maybe you will want
different kinds of leaders and what I
call a diversity of leadership it really
is about a diversity of values not just
diversity of gender or race you need to
create alternative paths to leadership
and what that really means is what is
the problem if it's not leaning in and
it's not confidence what's stopping
women and I believe it's the fact that
most jobs today at the very senior
levels require an inordinate amount of
time it's it's not a mystery it's not
rocket science it's that jobs today are
structured to require people to work 80
90 100 hours a week in order to achieve
success in the organization and to me
that is both short-sighted on behalf of
organizations because I don't think
they're getting the best of people and
they're limiting their talent pool and
obviously individuals who may desire to
exercise their talents if they're lucky
enough to have them to rise to the top
in a way that you know they can do it
with still allowing for other things in
their life so I think you've got to
reexamine how organizations are
structured and we think time so when we
think about time the fact that people
are working five days a week
810 hours a day is actually relatively
arbitrary it's a holdover from the
period of time when we were a forming
culture and you have to ask yourself why
does that matter what matters is the
amount of time we need to get a
particular piece of work done and how we
are going to apply talent against that
it's it's not as though there is a magic
to working five days a week or six days
a week eight hours a day or ten
that's just what we're used to this is
not rocket science it's not curing
cancer it's something that every
individual manager and every company has
the power to change and you the reason
you want to change it you want to think
about changing it is that you can expand
your talent pool there are a lot of
people on the sidelines who have
enormous talent but they want to work
differently they want to work three
months a year not 12 months a year they
want to work four days a week not five
days a week they want to work six hours
a day not 10 hours a day there are all
kinds of reasons that people have
different time commitments that'll work
for them and companies today are not
flexible enough to understand how to
accommodate and manage so that you can
take advantage of this talent pool and
if you open your aperture to think about
time differently then you will find
enormous resources available to you that
we're not available to you right now so
you absolutely you know will have
greater communication cost greater
teamwork cost but you will have such a
loyal and productive talent pool inside
of your company that those costs I think
are more than offset and our experience
has been that people who work
twenty-five hours a week are the most
efficient the most focused they know
they have time to do whatever else they
need to do in their life when they're
not working so they when they work they
really work if you hire somebody forty
fifty sixty hours a week the rest of
their life doesn't go away it just gets
squeezed in and so productivity is
impacted and I think you find that it
affects both satisfaction because people
always feel stretched and ultimately
productivity and so I feel from our
experience that the folks who are
working less than 40 hours a week are as
productive and maybe more productive
than the people who work more again it's
not right or wrong but it's an ability
to have a culture where not everybody
has made the decision that I'm going to
put my head down and only focus on my
work to the exclusion of other things in
my life because I
want to excel and I want to be a leader
you will be bringing in people who have
made different choices but may have just
as much talent and just as much ambition
actually and just as much Drive they
just want to do it in the smaller chunks